today we're going to talk about the
brace paradox a counterintuitive
phenomenon in traffic let's take a look
at the roads in New York City
specifically let's focus on 42nd Street
a busy crosstown road that is sight to
the United Nations Grand Central
Terminal and Times Square on Earth Day
in April 1990 New York City closed 42nd
Street the road closure was expected to
cause a nightmare of gridlock and
traffic jams but nothing of this sort
happened quite surprisingly traffic flow
in the city actually improved that
closing a road could improve traffic is
remarkable but it is not exclusive to
New York researchers have identified the
same principle for Boston if it closed
parts of Main Street and a similar
improvement could be made in London by
closing parts of the road that connects
the borough and Farringdon underground
stations and all this is just puzzling
because usually extra roads are built to
improve traffic so why does the brace
paradox happen let's do a simple example
consider two towns a and B that are
connected by roads there's a northern
set of roads and a southern set
historically each road takes a certain
amount of time the first road on the
northern route always takes 20 minutes
the second road is different its travel
time is T over 10 minutes where T is the
level of traffic if there are 200 cars
on the road for instance the travel time
will be 20 minutes but if there are only
a hundred cars then the travel time will
be 10 minutes just as we expect less
traffic corresponds to a shorter travel
time and a faster trip
the southern route is the same except in
Reverse now the first road takes T over
ten minutes and the second road takes 20
minutes flat now imagine there are 200
cars driving from A to B how long will
it take to get from A to B the answer
will depend on traffic since the two
routes are the same it's easy to
understand the equilibrium route that
the drivers will split up evenly
this means there will be a hundred
drivers to each route and we can
substitute that for the level of traffic
to find out that the roads of traffic
end up taking ten minutes apiece putting
this all together that means the total
travel time from A to B is thirty
minutes
this goes on for a while until city
planners decide to make a change
one day they build an extra road that
links the two routes at the midpoint now
drivers can instantly switch from one
route to another just like a train can
when switching from one track to another
the question is how will this traffic be
affected with the extra road we consider
the first choice of driving up to the
midpoint the northern path takes 20
minutes for sure the southern path takes
T over ten minutes and the time depends
on the traffic level T which can be as
little as zero cars or as much as 200
cars what is the right choice well the
decision is fairly simple in the worst
case all 200 drivers take the southern
route resulting in a travel time of 20
minutes this is no worse than the
northern route and if fewer cars take
the southern route then it will be
faster so the southern route is always
at least as
fast and therefore it's the right choice
at the halfway point it's the same
decision one option is the southern
route which takes 20 minutes and the
other option is to switch to the
northern route which takes T over 10
minutes in total now by the same logic
as before the T over 10 Road is going to
at least be as fast and therefore it's
the right choice
this logic holds true for every driver
and therefore we can conclude that all
200 cars take the same route this means
that T will equal 200 we can substitute
that value in and calculate that the
roads that depend on traffic take 20
minutes each adding it all together that
means the travel time from A to B will
be 40 minutes now let's compare the
travel times before and after the new
road before the new road we calculated
that it took 30 minutes to get from A to
B as the driver split up evenly between
the two routes but after the new road
the drivers preferred to take the roads
that depend on traffic the net result
was it takes 40 minutes to get from A to
B which is worse so adding the new road
has made the travel time worse for
everyone and that in a nutshell is an
example of the brace paradox the new
road has effect the decision of everyone
and this leads to a worse outcome for
the group the brays paradox can come up
in many situations in physics it can
affect how far a set of spring stretches
under a constant force in electricity
transmission it can affect the speed of
power being delivered on the grid
the braised paradox has also been used
in basketball to explain the Ewing
paradox that the New York Knicks could
have been a better scoring team when
they benched their best player the
lesson in all of these examples is that
flows on networks are complicated and
one should not blindly build roads or
extra capacity to try and fix traffic
thanks for watching and please subscribe
I make videos on math and game theory
you can also check me out at my blog
mind your decisions or on twitter at
pressure Walker and you can check out my
ebooks at Amazon